it is the kind of reception he doesn't
get every day this evening a module TM
is being celebrated like a superstar he
is the youngest member of parliament
ever elected in Mali this event is
taking place in Bamako districts fifth
commune Tien was born here for two years
now he has represented its constituents
in Parliament today his political
commitment is being rewarded for me this
is a symbol of appreciation and
encouragement say that together we may
build a better Mali Amma duty Ann was
elected on his first ever attempt to run
for Parliament back in 2013 when he was
barely twenty nine years old his
political career rapidly took off and
now he's vice president of the National
Assembly but his success hasn't only
made him friends to be honest
I'm often a victim of my own
outspokenness my sincere analysis of
governance issues has made me some
enemies a Madhu tiem studied
administration and finances in Accra and
Paris he originally started out as an
entrepreneur but as the crisis unfolded
in his country in 2012 and jihadists
took over in the north he decided he
could no longer just stand idly by so he
entered politics and money we felt it
was the end of Mali we saw what these
terrorists and drug smugglers did to
Timbuktu and gaol which they occupied
for several months they chopped off
people's hands flogged them there was no
democracy anymore
Mali was knocked out democracy on
imaginary money doesn't go at all a
Madhu TM wants a fresh start and more
responsibility for the younger
generation the average age in Mali is 16
the
most members of parliament are over
fifty years old TM has wide support
among other politicians he's very calm
and that's very important I am more
impulsive I'm a hothead that is also
part of being young but he expresses his
temperament in a different way in the
evening a Madhu TM meets up with a few
friends and colleagues at the Apollo
Grill which he says serves the best
dishes in his constituency he used to
dine here long before he was elected to
Parliament and will continue to do so
friends come to meet us here we greet
each other and chat a little bit they
need to understand we are always with
them with the people and that we have
not changed this he says is the real
malli who needs a chic five-star
restaurant